I didn't go to film school because I
couldn't get into film school I never
studied filmmaking in any way I started
making films when I was a kid when I was
I think seven years old making films
using my dad's Super 8 camera and little
action figures doing stop-motion films a
little bit of Animation certain amount
of live action and I think as a younger
man I struggled greatly with the idea
that well if somebody hasn't consciously
placed something into a work that
interpretation must be invalid there's a
notion of as a filmmaker you have to
struggle with the authorial intention of
a piece versus the way people interpret
it I studied English and what I found as
I studied it it greatly informed my
filmmaking process my writing process I
started to become more at ease with the
reason these things were evocative and
resonant is that they do have other
layers of subconscious layers of
resonant the film goer can pick up on
and interpret in their own way and that
is a valid approach and that was
something I in retrospect I very much
needed to to learn and get on board with